j'accueille andré dussollier
marc andré gide dites vous à regarder
henry v avec des yeux
j'aimerais qu'elle me regardent comme ça
mais vraiment alors mais il m'a aidé à
venir et c'est aux femmes voilées oui
ouais un bon comme ça c'est fait ça
s'est réglé règle et voilà après abbaoui
lui sait recevoir
alors deux spectacles théâtre andrea les
athlètes dans leur tête monstres sacrés
sacré monstre
et puis de film un long dimanche de
fiançailles 36 quai des orfèvres la
réunion avec une promo pas réussi leur
passage dans ocean's twelve on le voit
dans le bar de dos alors à commencer par
le théâtre vous reprenez au théâtre de
la gaîté montparnasse en alternance une
semaine sur deux par un jour sur deux
monstres sacrés sacré monstre et
athlètes dans leur tête
alors monstres sacrés sacré mons et des
textes de victor hugo de d'alphonse
allais d'alfred de vigny et puis les
sacs raymond c'est plutôt du billard et
économe en voilà et c'est une sorte
d'anthologie comme ça personnel qui que
je me suis amusé à composer
mais comme une petite pièce de théâtre
qui serait écrite par plusieurs auteurs
je vais intel souvent envie de faire ça
en vrai la matin le deux monstres sacrés
sacrément j'essaie de me souvenir et
demeureront shebab sur un petit texte
comme ça qui est en plein milieu du
montage
oui assez courant assez court bien que
le morse d'ordinaire certain animal
débonnaire il ne faut pas trop excité on
sait que les morts sont vite quand
quelque chose les irrite rien ne peut
plus les arrêter seul et je ne sais trop
gras ça qu'elle amorce les moujiks en
russie on dit ont le pouvoir de les
faire rentrer soudain dans le devoir
moralité le moujik adoucit les morts
c'est lui qui est un groupe s'appelle le
chat noir et l'or c'est un des dépôts
est de ce groupe là alors il ya monstres
sacrés sacrément seuil athlètes dans
leur tête donc mise en scène et
interprétation de vous envoie du soulier
sur des textes de paul fournel alors
c'est une espèce de dommages aux grands
sportifs parce que vous dites
les grands sportifs finalement plus on
les filme - on les connaît ses textes
les approcher plus près qu'une caméra ou
un micro
oui c'est vrai paul fournel qui connaît
bien le sport et qui venait bien les
sportifs les fait parler comme on les
entend jamais parler et dire des petites
choses comme ça en général les sportifs
c'est vrai il ya toujours un devoir de
réserve ne veulent pas déplaire aux
sponsors à l'entraîneur donc pendant
qu'ils exercent leur passion il parle
pas beaucoup et là paul fournel l'effet
dire des choses intimes de leur
difficulté pour sept petites secondes de
gloire
beaucoup de souffrance de doute et c'est
très savoureux même si on connaît pas
bien le sport mais c'est et en plus je
me suis amusé à les représenter en
pleine action parce que de toute façon
ils sont décrits en pleine action il ya
le footballeur qui rate une reprise de
volée ou cdc des petits moments de vie
de sportif qui sont là par exemple il ya
par exemple le match om psg il ya le
joueur qui se met à gamberger la
gamberge c'est pire qu'un un claquage
on se met à penser en jouant au ballon
c'est fini yann jeune boxeur qu'on
essaie de transformer en tueur
professionnel aussi c'est voilà à chaque
fois d'ailleurs on n'est pas toujours
sûr le personnage dont on parle
comment ce boxeur mais l'entraîneur puis
ensuite le masseur puis ensuite le
sophrologue tous nous tous ces gens qui
s'occupent de lui mais il va se répandre
comme peu bon comme on le suppose qu'on
imagine parce que souvent que ce soit le
tennisman cyclistes ils repèrent
quelqu'un dans le public comme ça alors
par exemple le cycliste y voit une femme
il imagine qu'elle est nu il se met à
penser à un strip-tease et puis bon
voila il perd quoi c'est oui où il
croise le regard d'une femme comme ça
dont il tombe amoureux puis commencer à
rêver sur elle le tout c'est aussi avec
une bande son qui nous met tout de suite
dans l'ambiance et la bombe sur la tiger
un contre un contre de nombreux produits
prendre la météo et la bande son est
très bien et risques dus c'est un show
c'est un spectacle à chaque fois le
sport maintenant donc il ya même ya même
des commentateurs il ya un elson monfort
qui elle a un qui dit quelques phrases
chocs sur un joueur de tennis
alors vous aimez pas trop vous dévoiler
voir moi je sais qu'une fois vous êtes
venus ici mais racontée par le biais des
rôles mais parce que faire pour vous
faire avouer avec isabelle adjani ça m'a
pris un quart d'heure vous dites
l'hyperconsommation de la vie réelle des
comédiens et dangereuse quoi s'attendre
et annecy pourquoi ce choix
alors